wie viel Leid kann eine Region ertragen
das ist die Innenstadt von tresson im
Süden der Ukraine
ich hoffe dass da nicht so viel Menschen
verletzte er ist einer der ganz wenigen
die sich trauen hierzu helfen Nils Tal
aus Deutschland Feuerwehrmann ist
freiwillig unterwegs in razon um die zu
retten die seit dem karowka Dammbruch
vom Wasser eingeschlossen sind er will
nicht nur zuschauen weil so viel Leid
muss er einfach helfen
hier soll noch jemand sein
der Mann der selbst nicht mehr laufen
kann konnte nicht fliehen viele haben
mehrere Tage ausharren müssen bis
endlich Hilfe kommt manche verletzt ohne
Trinkwasser oder Lebensmittel
doch auch die rettende Fahrt zurück ist
gefährlich
wir sind da vorhin nicht abgebogen
aber wenn man hier sieht gibt es
Gartenzäune mit spitzen dran
und die sind nicht alle gleich hoch
manche sind auch direkt direkt unter der
Wasserlinie und da würden uns das Boot
aufreißen deswegen können wir leider
nicht über hinfahren
jeden Mensch jedes Lebewesen dass sie
finden und sicher an Land bringen ist
ein kleines Wunder in diesem riesigen
Meer an Wasser dass ich über dem Gebiet
ergossen hat und als wäre die
Überschwemmung nicht Katastrophe genug
gibt es Beschuss im Evakuierungsgebiet
über mehrere Stunden dauert der Angriff
die Rettung müssen abgebrochen werden
und auch in den nächsten Tagen hört es
nicht auf
wir sind eine Beschuss geraten wir sind
rein als als also es ist eigentlich
permanent Dauerbeschuss es ist immer mal
wieder Pause jetzt haben wir gerade
Pause wir haben uns beim ersten Schuss
noch nicht viel gedacht weil das einfach
leider Normalität ist und dann ist es
intensiver geworden und dann sind wir
eben Entdeckung gegangen gegen diese
hinterhältigen Angriffe kommen selbst
die mutigsten kaum an es sind nur wenige
die sich überhaupt hierher trauen kleine
lokale Hilfsorganisation koordinierte
internationale Nothilfe fehlt und die
Lage in den russisch besetzten Gebieten
sollen noch schlimmer sein diese Frau
hat es von dort nach Hessen geschafft
sie wurde Zeugen die unter dem Beschuss
ein Mensch ums Leben kam der Präsident
selbst kurz vorher in Hassan kritisiert
die mangelnde internationale Hilfe aufs
Schärfste
wenn internationale Organisationen die
eigentlich dafür da sind Leben auf
globaler Ebene zu beschützen nicht die
Zeit finden eine Rettungsmission
innerhalb einer Woche zu organisieren
und zu schicken werden Terroristen nur
angeheizt von dieser Schwäche der Welt
dieser Gleichgültigkeit es bestärkt sie
doch auch im von der Ukraine
kontrollierten Gebiet erreicht die
kleinen Dörfer auch mehrere Tage nach
der Überschwemmung kaum Hilfe diese
lokale Organisation verteilt das
Nötigste Wasser Brot eine warme Mahlzeit
hier treffen wir Ihre Hongo die Essen zu
ihrer Mutter bringen möchte sie ist im
überschwemmten Dorf geblieben wegen der
Schweine von denen sie lebt
meine Mutter rief mich panisch an und
sagte sie werden überschwemmt sie sagte
beeil dich und rette Vater
zum Glück hat mein Mann ein Boot das
haben wir schnell aufgepumpt etwas essen
Brot und Wasser geschnappt und sind zu
ihnen gefahren
sie nehmen uns mit zu ihrer Familie nach
wowo fassilifka das war mal ein kleiner
Nebenfluss des nipro mit den
Wassermassen kamen Land Minen
angeschwemmt tote Tiere und erste
Untersuchungen zeigen es wurde eine
massive Verschlechterung der
Wasserqualität gemessen waren es mit dem
Auto vorher wenige Minuten braucht es
nun ein Boot
das Dorf ist fast komplett abgeschnitten
ihrer erzählt sie hatte so große Angst
als das Wasser immer höher stieg und
alles was hier mal war verschluckt hat
an Land wartet ihrer Schwester Nadia
gemeinsam haben sie versucht so viele
ihrer Tiere zu retten wie möglich doch
die Strömung war irgendwann zu stark um
zu bleiben
dann sehen sie ihre Mutter wieder
weine nicht
[Musik]
meine Beine tun so weh
ich kann kaum noch laufen
ich habe nichts mehr nicht mal essen Gas
zum Kochen einfach nichts mehr
sie hat ihr Leben lang so hart
gearbeitet für Ihr Haus ihre Kühe wovon
soll sie jetzt nur leben
luboff osterpenko zeigt uns wo einmal
ihr Paradies war
hier waren überall Blumen es war so
schön die Rosen haben gerade angefangen
zu blühen alles Rosen das ist einfach so
schmerzhaft das zu sehen
sie haben die Besatzung der Russen
überstanden Kämpfe und Beschuss doch das
Wasser hat der Familie endgültig alles
genommen
alles ist kaputt ich habe das Haus mit
meinen eigenen Händen gebaut ich habe
die Steine dafür im Dorf selbst
gesammelt
und jetzt ist alles weg
das Haus war ihr Langzeitprojekt wenn
ein bisschen Geld da war hat die Mutter
daran gebaut
mein ganzes Leben habe ich davon
geträumt dass hier meine Küche ist wo
ich mit meiner Familie zusammen sitze
wie soll es weitergehen wo sollen sie
leben was bleibt wenn das Wasser geht
die Verzweiflung und Wut spüren wir im
gesamten Dorf
die Not ist so groß und die mutigen
Helfer weniger
die ersten Hilfsgüter die das THW vor
fast einer Woche losgeschickt hat sind
inzwischen in der Ukraine angekommen sie
werden dringend benötigt
Nils Thal erzählt uns es fehlt einfach
an allem Medikamente Möglichkeiten zur
Wasseraufbereitung erst unterwegs auf
eigene Faust in die kleinen Dörfer er
wünschte er könnte noch so viel mehr tun